Britain's Prime Minister back at work
after recovering from coronavirus with a
warning that there will be no let-up in
the lockdown yet I can see the long-term
consequences of lockdown as clearly as
anyone and so yes I entirely share your
urgency it's the government's urgency
and yet we must also recognize the risk
of a second spike more than 21,000
people have now died from coronavirus in
UK hospitals in one of the world's worst
outbreaks the government has announced
that the families of national health
workers who've died from coronavirus
during this crisis will receive a
$75,000 payout the number of tests being
offered in the UK is being expanded but
the government has faced criticism for
the slow rollout of mass testing and
there are growing frustrations and
questions even within Boris Johnson's
own party about how soon the economy can
reopen Italy has set a date to start
easing its lock down the longest in
Europe factories and building sites can
reopen next week bars and restaurants
can fully reopen in June while schools
will stay shut until September many
parts of Europe are grappling with the
impact of this crisis there is anger in
some of France's poorest suburbs the
lockdown and restrictions on movement in
communities where people often live in
cramped conditions has led to unrest the
police have been accused of being heavy
handed in their approach racial slurs
were allegedly used to mock a man trying
to escape arrest last week my Crusades
that we friends was going you know on
the war and against the coronavirus but
it seems like France is at war against
its own mineral riches you know so it's
difficult because people are suffering
from this virus they are suffering from
the economic and social impacts there is
optimism in some parts of Europe that
the worst of this crisis may be over the
still no unified approach in how to keep
safe going forward in most parts of
Germany people will have to wear face
masks in shops and on public transport
elsewhere some families are seeing one
another for the first time in weeks
albeit through the glass but together
all the same
Emma Haywood al-jazeera